[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya con nosotros esta
mañana de jueves Marta ya estamos casi
finalizando semana y vamos a abrir
nuestra revista de prensa siendo repaso
por los medios internacionales sobre qué
sobre diferentes noticias relacionadas
con la guerra en Ucrania empezamos
destacando que dice al yesira sobre las
declaraciones del presidente ucraniano
pueblo
sanciones contra Rusia esto porque por
los ataques a la infraestructura
energética por supuesto de cara al
invierno un invierno Según la OMS es
supervivencia para los ciudadanos
ucranianos así a Raúl buenos días vamos
a empezar con las yasiera que recoge las
declaraciones de celenski que dice
fórmula del terror y que celenski
implora a la ONU que se sancione a Rusia
estas declaraciones las hizo en una
reunión en una participación online en
el consejo de seguridad de Naciones
Unidas y a razón de los ataques aéreos
contra la infraestructura civil que ayer
como decía nuestra corresponsal Catalina
atacaron con 70 misiles a sobre todo
Quién fue una de las ciudades más
afectadas donde viven en esa área urbana
tres millones de personas no y esto
selenski dice que son crímenes de guerra
porque ataca a la población civil aunque
sea de manera indirecta una población
civil indefensa en los misiles además de
matar a 10 personas Pues supusieron el
cierre de plantas de energía nuclear
cortaron el suministro de agua y
electricidad en muchos lugares de todo
el país y esa fórmula del terror es la
que dice que celenski que Rusia está
empleando contra los ucranianos ya a las
puertas ahora sí que sí del Invierno sin
embargo según el representante de Rusia
ante la ONU Brasil critica que hubiera
participado en el Consejo de Seguridad y
además dice que los daños contra la
infraestructura civil pertenecen a esas
fuerzas de defensa aérea ucranianas que
queriendo derribar a misiles rusos
terminaron por atacar a infraestructura
ucra Qué dice el New York time is Marta
hoy recogemos un artículo de New York
Times que dice que un misil fabricado en
Estados Unidos se extravió en Ucrania e
hirió a civiles Esto ocurrió en el mes
de septiembre en la ciudad del este de
Ucrania en cromators y tres civiles
habrían quedado heridos por este impacto
de un misil de fabricación
estadounidense
los periodistas del New York Times
fueron allí después del ataque y
pudieron reunir e identificar pruebas de
los restos del metal y además
comprobaron que el ensamblaje del
circuito eléctrico solo se usaba en este
misil de fabricación estadounidense pasó
el 27 de septiembre en esta ciudad
Industrial que ha sido escenario de
continuos ataques con misiles y
artillería por parte de la ofensiva de
Rusia en Ucrania que dice de Guardian
Marta esta hagamos un artículo de The
Guardian que dice que las familias de
soldados rusos reclutados acusan a
Vladimir Putin de despreciarlos todo
ello porque cuando se cumplen meses
desde que Putin iniciara esta
movilización parcial de reservistas ha
reunido o va a reunir a madres y esposas
de estos reservistas para calmar un poco
los temores de que haya una convocatoria
en contra del presidente por la
desatención que está teniendo el
gobierno ruso con estas familias de
reservistas Los Defensores de las
familias han dicho que el kremín está
escenificando esta reunión pero que
están siendo ignorados por el gobierno
Ruso y además destaca este artículo de
The Guardian unas declaraciones de
Valentina melnikova que es una defensora
de Derechos Humanos que dice que no le
han invitado y que además está siendo
muy complicado reunir las quejas por la
represión del gobierno ruso tanto en la
disidencia online como en las
manifestaciones públicas rápidamente
finalizamos este tema con medusa Marta y
como lo comentábamos en el informativo
la duma del Estado aprueba una ley que
prohíbe la propaganda lgtb entre todas
las edades no esto ha sido aprobado por
400 Diputados es una ley que ya se venía
tramitando y que hoy ha hecho su lectura
final con esta decisión y como decíamos
Raúl pues al final se prohíbe la
propaganda en relaciones no
tradicionales sobre las personas lgtb la
propaganda sobre la pedofilia y en
internet en películas en la publicidad
en todos los medios no y decíamos que la
horquilla de sanciones por infringir
esta ley va desde los 3.000 dólares
hasta los casi 83.000 Así es Marta vamos
a cambiar de tema porque ayer conocimos
que el gobierno del presidente
venezolano Nicolás maduro y la oposición
de ese país se van a sentar por décimo
quinta vez en una mesa de diálogos a
partir de este fin de semana
en México que hay de nuevo porque se van
a sentar esta vez parece que las
negociaciones de lln en Caracas
presionaron no y despertaron nuevamente
la posición a decir al gobierno vamos a
sentarnos usted y yo para negociar el
futuro de nuestra nación así Raúl vamos
a empezar con el país Aunque la
exclusiva la dio verdaderamente como
pueden ver y luego la confirmó el
presidente de Colombia Gustavo Petro se
van a reunir y en unas condiciones mucho
más favorables para Nicolás Maduro no
porque ya se reunieron en 2021 y después
cortaron las negociaciones tras la
detención de Alexa que es un empresario
colombiano muy afín a Nicolás maduro y
se espera que ahora estas conversaciones
avancen porque sobre todo Estados Unidos
ha relajado o quiere relajar las
sanciones para impulsar también esa
industria petrolera el espectador que
dice el espectador se pregunta no Por
qué negociar ahora y lo que comentaba no
las condiciones son mucho más favorables
ahora que hace un año
explícitamente por la relajación de las
sanciones no sólo Estados Unidos sino
también de todo el bloque occidental
para con el gobierno de Nicolás maduro
que dice la agencia de noticias
destacamos también una exclusiva que
dice que Estados Unidos estaría
preparando una autorización para que
Chevron pudiera impulsar la producción
de petróleo en Venezuela chevrones
petrolera estadounidense que tiene bueno
que tiene la licencia para operar en
Venezuela y que estas negociaciones
habrían podido facilitar que se vayan a
retomar los diálogos donde se van a
tratar temas de la sociedad venezolana y
además cuando se van a celebrar esas
elecciones que Probablemente van a ser
en 2024 Bueno vamos a ver qué pasa con
esa mesa de negociaciones entre el
gobierno venezolano y la oposición
esperemos que finalmente llegan a un
acuerdo Marta como siempre Gracias por
toda la información mañana con más
revista de prensa y saludamos nosotros